chut faut pas parler trop fort parce
qu'on est dimanche et le dimanche je
sais que vous dormez vous vous réveillez
dans votre lit pour regarder
l'explication du dimanche
aujourd'hui comme tous les dimanches je
vous explique quelque chose qui va vous
permettre de bluffer votre entourage
aujourd'hui ou dans la semaine peu
importe on va partir sur un forçage
psychologique c'est pas exactement ce
que je voulais faire ce dimanche du coup
je dire l'idée pour la semaine prochaine
où vous apprendrez à trouver quel prénom
pense quelqu'un et sera pas un tour de
magie on serait vraiment dur du
mentalisme mais cette semaine j'ai une
autre idée en discutant un peu avec vous
dans les commentaires
quelqu'un parler de quelque chose je dis
pas encore quoi sinon ça va gâcher la
surprise et je me suis mais ça vous dira
qu'ils connaissent pas ça et il y en a
plein qui m'ont dit oui dont on connaît
pas on connaît pas et je pensais que
c'était ultra connus on va commencer je
vais déjà vous faire la démonstration
si vous connaissez ne vous inquiétez pas
aller jusqu'au bout parce que je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi ça marche et
comment faire en sorte que ça marche
encore mieux et à 100% ou en tout cas
proche de 100% le 100% n'existe pas dans
le mentalisme et si vous connaissez pas
et bien johri dans un premier temps vous
allez vous concentrez vous allez jouer
le jeu avec moi vous rester bien
concentrés sur la vidéo
si vous avez des écouteurs sont encore
mieux ne vous laissez surtout pas
distraire vous allez répondre le plus
rapidement possible avoir faute
alors si c'est compliqué de parler parce
que vous êtes dans le métro vous
chuchoter mais vous répondez vraiment à
voix haute à des petits calculs
arithmétiques simple que je vais vous
faire
on commence soft c'est parti attention
ça va être très rapide de l'es22 + 3 1
plus 1 2 x 5
attention plus dur cette +49 +2 et
maintenant instantanément sans réfléchir
je veux que vous souhaitiez ou que vous
disiez à voix haute un outil est une
couleur maintenant tout de suite un
outil est une couleur et là je vous
remercie d'avoir bien voulu penser à un
marteau rouge est évidemment peut-être
que certains d'entre vous ont pensé à
autre chose un tournevis par exemple ou
à la couleur bleue ou encore à des
choses complètement hallucinante si
c'est le cas a dit le mois dans les
commentaires pour qu'on se marre mais le
taux de réussite en suivant la méthode
de base de demandes et spontanément à
quelqu'un un outil est une couleur et de
78% mais on peut passer la barre des 90%
voire même plus en appliquant deux
astuces la poire astuce est de saturer
le cerveau rationnel on dit qu'il a le
cerveau droit et cerveau gauche ça c'est
des images mais notre but c'est de
saturé d'informations le cerveau
rationnel pour avoir accès à
l'inconscient je vous dis pourquoi juste
après donc pour le saturer faut
l'occuper et vous allez l'occupé avec
des opérations très simple mais ça c'est
pour faire
focalisé le conscient et le rationnel là
dessus une fois qu'il est bien occupée
vous demander une réponse spontanée vous
pressez la personne vous claquer les
doigts en même temps vous dites
maintenant maintenant dix mois un outil
une couleur notre but c'est qu'elle
réfléchisse pas si elle réfléchit alvaro
passer par le rationnel et ça nous
intéresse pas du tout puisque on veut
avoir
l'inconscient si on laisse les manettes
à la conscience spontanément il va
répondre marteau et rouge pourquoi la
couleur rouge parce que c'est la
première couleur qui nous vient c'est la
couleur essentielle dans notre vie tout
ce qui est important depuis l'école a
été souligné en rouge ou écrit en rouge
tout ce qui est important ou interdits
et mis en rouge tous les panneaux de
circulation vraiment dangereux ou
d'interdiction sont mis en rouge le sang
c'est rouge donc ça représente la vie ça
représente la mort on est marqué par le
rouge c'est pas la couleur préférée
forcément mais c'est une couleur assez
marquante pour que l'inconscient la
ressort tout de suite et pourquoi
marteau parce que la plupart d'entre
nous on n'est pas des grand bricoleur on
bricole pas souvent quand vous le faites
des fois les vrais gros bricoleur vous
allez des surprises d'ailleurs donc le
marteau c'est le premier outil dont
s'est servi la première action manuelle
qu'on a tous effectués c'est de taper
sur quelque chose
depuis notre plus tendre enfance même si
on n'est pas bricoleur on a déjà fait
sur quelque chose pour le faire rentrer
donc quand on dit outil on pense à un
manuel et quand on pense à manuel on
pense à ce qu'on attrape et le geste le
plus simple qu'on peut faire avec un
objet qu'on attrape c'est ap c'est donc
le marteau et voici pourquoi
spontanément tout le monde dit mme
arthaud rouge pour le présentez vous
pouvez prédire en l'écrivant l avance
sur un papier vous pouvez en faire aussi
un test psychologique vous pouvez faire
la présentation que vous voulez c'est
très drôle forcément vous pourrez le
faire qu'une seule fois à chaque
personne une fois que c'est fait s'est
cramé ou leur ferai plus jamais c'est
pour ça que les quelques personnes qui
ont regardé la vidéo et qui connaissait
déjà on a pu leur faire et je pensais
que c'était extrêmement connu et en
discutant avec vous dans les
commentaires
j'étais très étonné de voir qu'il y
avait beaucoup de personnes qu'il
connaissait pas d'où l'objet de cette
vidéo de dimanche
je vous ai donc déjà annoncé ce que
j'allais vous expliquer dimanche
prochain mais il va se passer de manière
plein de choses cette semaine un grand
merci je le fais pas tous les jours mais
vraiment merci à tous ceux qui sous
titre les vidéos c'est vraiment cool ça
permet aux malentendants de pouvoir
suivre toutes ces vidéos là et c'est
vous qui faites le top donc merci merci
à vous la regardez c'est moi qui voulais
un pouce en l'air et si vous avez aimé
la vidéo vous pouvez en mettre un en
retour demain dans la journée je vous
poserai une question je sais pas encore
si je vais la poser sur facebook twitter
instagram ou snat je verrai en tout cas
je relaierai l'info sur les autres et
sociaux pour vous dire pour répondre
pour
ville et toutes les réponses au même
endroit ce sera pour faire une vidéo
jeudi avec vous et beaucoup grâce à
passer un excellent dimanche je n'oublie
pas de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de
partir le mental blog c'est une vidéo
par jour pendant un an alors rendez vous
demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
mentale blog ciao